in just three days the Jeremy's razer's
Twitter account surpasses Harry's in
followers so many of you heard a little
bit already about this you know a little
bit about it for those that aren't
familiar Harry's Razors is woke they
denounced the daily wires audience the
daily wire launched their uh their own
version essentially Jeremy's razors
which now has a what do you say Jeremy
25 000 subscriptions 25 000
subscriptions in 72 hours I'll just say
real quick and we can get to the
beginning the story of all this
um the building of culture the building
of infrastructure which means the
ability for someone to buy a razor you
know people watch Netflix because where
else can you go well now the daily wires
got something people buy Harry's Razors
because or Gillette because they need
razors and these companies are investing
your money in things that you don't
value or in people that hate you so what
the daily wire is doing is profoundly
important many people are doing it but
you guys seem to be leading the charge
so Jeremy do you want you want to tell
us just a bit about how this started yep
your position and where you're at yeah
absolutely I mean what you said I think
is is a big part of it like
conservatives have been you know sort of
in Retreat for most of my life certainly
for the last uh 15 or 20 years and as a
result of that
we've we've sort of taken a very
pessimistic view conservatives spent a
lot of time lamenting the loss of the
past lamenting uh the loss of the
economy lamenting the loss of their
place in the culture and daily wire has
a different attitude we're we're not
lamenting anything we're we're happy to
be alive right now like I'm glad that we
live at a time where uh black people
people can drink from the same water
fountains that I do I'm glad whatever
water fountain is I mean I guess they
can drink from the same water bottles
right that I can and I'm glad that uh
yeah we have Penicillin like there's a
lot of this great about the Modern Age
um what I want to do is take the great
values that were established and worked
in the past learn from the past and
build on a foundation I want to be
proactive I want to I want to be
optimistic about the future I don't want
to lament the past I want to build the
future and so when someone like Harry's
virtue signals publicly and attacks my
business
um
I want to build my own business like
conservatives deserve razors too and and
I think that it's an important you know
the the left these World corporations
they think that they can sort of rip the
culture in half and not pay any economic
consequence for it so I want to rip the
economy in half I want to say no
if you can't just alienate 50 of the
audience of the people in the country
and still expect them to buy your goods
and services they should buy their own
goods and services and that sounds like
I'm saying that I think we should be
further balkanized that I think that we
should be further divided I do in the
short term but I don't in the long term
I desire a country where we're all
citizens together where we can where we
can Embrace disagreement where we can
Embrace political processes I just think
things are so out of alignment right now
that to return to a place like that you
have to create economic incentive and
the only way to create economic
incentive it's not with temporary
boycotts uh it's not with complain
culture online it's not with doom
scrolling it's with actively building
things that require that now require
companies like Harry's to compete for
our business exactly competition
competition so so uh did Harry's have
any wind of what you guys were planning
on doing or do you want to just give us
the quick version of the story for
anyone who doesn't know absolutely so
one of the people who works for me a
peon named Michael Noel
I know none of you have ever heard of
him who who has Michael was on a podcast
with another of our host Candice Owens
but it was not a daily wire podcast it
was a Prager University podcast and it
wasn't uh a year ago it was several
years ago wow and they had a
conversation about how gender dysphoria
has historically been categorized as a
mental illness I believe it is it
currently in the DSM-5 and it was that
was the conversation it was a
respectable conversation a respectful
conversation uh fast forward a couple of
years one year ago in March one year ago
right now and a Twitter account that had
two followers a high schooler a high
schooler with two followers uh pointed
out to Harry's uh that this conversation
had taken place and Harry's immediately
reacted on their Twitter account and
said you know this is inexcusable this
is values misalignment we're pulling all
of our ads uh and we're gonna and we're
gonna make sure there's no further
values misalignment and how we and how
we conduct our sponsorships well when
you do that
you're signaling to all of my other
advertisers that the only excusable
thing to do would be to also pull your
business from the daily wire that makes
it an attack on my business right it's
not just you taking your spend which you
can do anytime you want it's you
attacking your company a company that
had been your partner previously it's
also attacking my audience you're saying
my entire audience an audience you paid
us
to go help you sell razors to has
inexcusable values
and I'm just not going to put up with
that anymore I think one of the beauties
of this medium that we all have this
this digital presence that we all have
is that there are so many fewer
Gatekeepers I don't have to make you
know the radio syndication Network happy
uh they that radio syndication Network
wants you to just take cancellations
laying down because they have other
shows they don't want to get into a war
with the advertisers but you know with
your show with our shows we're still
going to have the same number of people
watching tomorrow
note whether Harry's Razors advertises
with us or not so why wouldn't I embrace
that freedom why wouldn't I use that
that that same amount of time that I
used to spend telling people to buy
Harry's which by the way Harry's is a
great razor I was proud to tell people
to buy Harry's that's proud that we
supported the work that you know
supported their product but they don't
want my audience to buy their razors
clearly and so I'm going to spend that
same amount of time telling my audience
that Harry's doesn't want their business
and I do and you're going to make more
money
do you ever think that adding like an
extension to the handle of the razor
would be good so you could shave your
back yeah absolutely well it sounds
dangerous yeah it could be yeah a little
bit yeah maybe put a warning label back
shaving with that that would do it no
but just thinking it for the future just
in case a back shaver we all we all have
back shaper problem back shape at some
point like women are having the day but
the day is coming that's right yeah so
so where are you at can you mention how
many subscriptions 25 000 subscriptions
we've sold uh in 72 hours which makes us
the dog who caught the car I mean for us
the commercial was everything and this
is what I told my team all year we were
sourcing razors we were mixing up
shaving creams and seeing if we liked
them what was important to me though was
whether we ever sell a razor or not the
commercial has to be a statement about
the daily wire it has to be a statement
about our brand it has to say that we're
proactive that we're having a good time
that we're looking to the Future that
we're not going to take cancellations
laying down
um it has to remind our audience what we
are and what we stand for if we happen
to sell any razors it'll just make the
joke that much funnier well now I'm the
dog who caught the car I have an actual
business now I have to stand up over the
next two weeks to make sure that we can
keep up with the demand that's out there
for these races is it that a year a year
ago I just want to get the timeline
actually a year ago they pulled the ads
a year ago they pulled the ad so you've
been in in the process this last year
building everything and how long did it
take to produce the commercial
it was a three-day shoot and and uh five
or six weeks of post-production to get
the commercial out nice five million
views since the 22nd so not even two
full days it's 4.9 million views yeah
it's amazing oh is that a real flame bro
it's a real flamethrower it's not the
smartest idea I ever had to fire a
flamethrower in my office but it's
definitely the most badass and it works
it's a boring company yeah is it made by
the boring company it is the boring
company
fired the boring flamethrower it was not
boring
oh that's awesome do you believe in
Synergy like in like Divine inner
Confluence and things I definitely
believe that if Elon Musk will retweet
my Razor Company I will sell even more
bajillions of razor blades yeah I I'll
actually this will be the most kiss-assy
thing that I say on the show Elon Musk
is the greatest living American he's the
most important person in the country
because he has an affirmative vision for
the future of the country I don't I
don't know it's politics I'm sure I
disagree with him on 50 of everything
but that's a guy who has a vision for
what we can be tomorrow he's not he's
not one of these like Boomer lefties
who's still fighting the cultural
revolution of the 1960s or the economic
revolution of the 19 teens and 20s in
Europe you know trying to socialize the
country and he's not a boomer
conservative who's just talking about
how great things used to be back when we
were still young and rock and roll he's
a guy who's going no no we can actually
build some we can build our best days
are ahead of us let's go build them we
were talking about leadership last night
and Savannah Hernandez saying we need
leaders and I thought yeah you don't but
you what you don't want is a guy to step
on be like I'm Your Leader now you want
someone like Elon or like you that's
like building something that people can
you're just casually building it and
people look at you like a leader because
of what you've created what you're
creating I agree with you that I'm a lot
like Elon yeah your Beard's very nice by
the way I don't know if I mentioned that
earlier and I think for for the average
person you know they would they just
look at Elon and you as very very
wealthy successful people who have a
vision for something Elon though is you
know one of the is he the richest guy
the richest guy on the planet I think
it's a good sport I think Bezos has
ahead of him no I think it doesn't even
if Bezos is ahead today you just have to
remember that SpaceX hasn't gone public
oh wow all of elon's wealth really is
Tesla right I mean when we think of his
vast wealth is Tesla what happens when
you take SpaceX public I mean the the
amount of money that that guy is
actually worth I think is dude he called
it starlink I think he's actually going
to be linking star systems with that
yeah I don't know maybe one day he'll
build a Dyson Sphere but I think we're a
long way a long ways away from that
well time time can condense you know
when you have a lot of time and space or
the same thing so if you can move fast
enough you can and therefore a lot of
people are working together it kind of
condenses time too and if you have
drones building things all at once in
space you can compile like large
spacecraft really quickly
self-replicating machines we send off to
other planets perhaps to just carry on
the American Vision perfect that's it
that's the end of existence I think you
make an interesting point it's true that
unfortunately a lot of what conservative
has been conservatives have been doing
for the past 10 or 20 years is more or
less just been complaining about the
left and it's really important for us to
forward our own Vision that's a huge
part of what I try to do agree or
disagree with me that's part of why I'm
frequently talking about my faith and my
own particular vision for conservatism
because even though I enjoy making fun
of the left and pulling them apart we
actually have to give people something
that they can believe in instead of just
saying that's bad don't do it well let's
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more 4. special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there